bonjour aujourd'hui on est au mwc à
barcelone avec marc d'alcatel on est sur
le stand d'alcatel et alcatel à de
nouveaux produits dont des smartphones
haut de gamme
marx et le alcatel 5 à l'a45
[Musique]
donc alcatel 5 qui m'a montré un petit
peu ce qu'on pouvait faire alors c'est
quoi l'idée de ce produit c'est d'abord
un produit haut de gamme facile à
prendre en main qu'on peut utiliser et
qui est pas cher surtout c'est cher
c'est pas cher c'est pas schalke c'est
des 129 11 129 euros
c'est la qualité prime c'est bon
donc 229 euros pour un téléphone haut de
gamme de chez alcatel c'est pas cher on
peut faire du partage d'écran aurait
alors deux attirent sweet asking les
partage d'écran caméra aussi nous avons
trois caméras ici trois caméras en
talent et en ici oui deux frontale qui
sont là pour les seules filles unis si
on peut faire le portrait de mode avec
le côté blur derrière les faits évoqués
pour eux de faire du collard et protos
il est là posté via
et les caméras sont ici c'est du smag
attifel à l'arrière wimille 16,8 à la
vente donc une ouverture de 2 au niveau
de la caméra ici 120,50 angles d'accord
on a un écran 5,7 pouces ok 5 kw à 7 c
du lcd
donc il est disponible en 3 3 giga de
ram à l'intérieur 32 gigas de stockage
ok ça va il s'adresse à qui ce téléphone
qui léchait pour qui les fait pas en un
clic et qu'ils cherchent
et près en même temps la qualité combien
téléphonie
les marchés escomptaient
qualité l'écran
parce que si vous comparez cela avec son
8 plus et c'est trés fond c'est 15% plus
vite
proportionnellement
c'est lui
vous voyez
la vidéo
ok c'est un produit qui sera disponible
quand il sera disponible et ça dépend de
la fin je pense à l'espagne je ne sais
pas c est peut-être fin mars
s'ils habitent là ça dépasse ok alors
moi c'est le seul truc que je trouve
bizarre sur ce téléphone
c'est la grande bordure en trouve
qu'effectivement il a une très grande
bordures pour avoir les capteurs photo
aujourd'hui on voit que les écrans plus
de place et là c'est vrai que il ya il
ya une différence de proportions entre
le haut et le bas
le haut est très grand le var plus petit
et c'est ça qui est un petit peu
surprenant après c'est vrai que l'écran
est sympa le produit premium la prise
jack en haut c'est cédule usb fixé c'est
quoi
motif ces noms mais sinon après c'est
vrai que c'est un produit qui est bien
c'est tout cas le mérite pas cher et
d'avoir une bonne qualité une qualité
alcatel ça c'est vrai que c'est plutôt
pas mal
après voilà il faut tous les personnes
qui aiment l'esthétique qui craignent
pas ça c'est pas mal en terme de budget
il ya un côté arrondi sur le côté qui
est sympa c'est joli et bien de quelle
heure
en or alors
est-ce que tu qu'autre chose à rajouter
sur ce téléphone ne s'est pas à l'écrin
s'est prononcé
très bon mais ça c'est ça
s'arrêter
sensation la cessation c'est que ces 25
5.4 à l'écran mais c'est simple c'est
parce qu'elle nous
cette fois d'abord
il arrive au port et arrive au bord sur
les côtés c'est vrai que c'est un
borderless sur les côtés sabordant la
sensation d'immersion c'est vrai que
c'est un valet qu'ont ils à matéri aussi
c'est
faire semblant oui on le disait partant
le jure
super merci beaucoup c'est à twitter
merci merci ma vérité de fans
oui dix mois merci à vous dites moi ce
que vous en pensez en commentaire est-ce
que vous avez déjà des produits de chez
alcatel est ce que c'est un smartphone
qui pourrait vous intéresser
mark et moi tout ça j'ai hâte d'avoir
votre avis par rapport au design du
produit est ce qui peut vous intéresser
par rapport à la marque vous mettez tout
ça en commentaire merci beaucoup de
regarder la vidéo vous invite à vous
abonner va jouer comme d'habitude on va
parler toujours plus de nouveaux
produits innovants de smartphones là où
elles ewc ya énormément de choses c'est
top
merci beaucoup à bientôt